Valar morghulis all men die so with the
seventh season of Game of Thrones behind
us I still kind of have Game of Thrones
on the brain and that has queued me to
want to revisit some of the lists I did
about the show before but I was kind of
hard pressed and thinking about what I
wanted to do I'm wasn't entirely sure I
wanted to do a best characters list
again because largely that hasn't
changed
I thought about revisiting my worst
characters list because that one has
changed from the last time I've done it
significantly so except that that one
changed in such a way that it almost
doesn't feel worth doing because the
reason that oldest change was a lot of
the characters I didn't like turned out
to have a really good arcs over time
that just hadn't paid off yet at the
time I did that list so it's actually
not even topping I really feel like I
want to deal with anymore not to mention
that's one of the most disliked videos I
ever did so instead I'm going to revisit
my best game of Thrones deaths lists
which is the one I had the most fun with
anyways so I'm gonna go through what I
think are the 10 best deaths and exactly
what makes any specific death good or
bad is gonna vary some of these are just
viscerally satisfying some of them are
traumatic some of them are impactful and
all of them are great and there are some
great deaths that are not gonna make
this list you can go back and look at my
older list and compare and realize that
some of these things got bumped off with
some of the newer deaths that we got in
the last few years since I did this last
so oh and I should not have to say this
but serious spoilers coming up for the
show okay that's enough preamble let's
get into this thing with number 10
Catelyn Stark I'm gonna tell you right
now this is the only deaths from the red
wedding that is gonna be on this list
and that should tell you the kind of
caliber of deaths that we're dealing
with here that it was the only red
wedding just to make it on here the
reason I picked this one over the other
ones is Rob's wife I think is the most
shocking one Rob himself is possibly the
most you know deflating as an audience
member but for me there's something
about Catelyn Stark's death you know
just screaming at Rob to
to run and he doesn't even have the
strength anymore and she's just watching
everything fall apart and she's
threatening Walder Frey's wife and he
just doesn't care and she knows that at
this point nothing she does matters and
in this really quiet horrible traumatic
moment she just cuts this woman's throat
because it's the only thing she can do
it doesn't make a difference but she's
gonna do something and then she just
stands there same thing is done to her
and it's such a defeated moment and I
think for me it's the debt that sums up
the red wedding the best of all of
deaths that happened at the red wedding
so that's why that one is the one that
makes the list moving up a slob we're
gonna go to number nine Tommen Baratheon
there's just something really cool about
how quiet and unassuming and for me like
wool this depth was he is alone in his
room he's looking out the window at the
destruction at what his mother is rot we
have no idea if you realize his mother
is the one who caused this or not I
think he probably did suspect I think
he's smart enough for that but
regardless he is just watched so much
that he cares about literally go up in
smoke takes off the crown walks off
camera walks back into camera into the
window down
gone just the the quietness of it and
just he obviously just made them the
decision like well that's it I'm done
and out he goes and it man it's shocking
in a and in a way that's distinctly
different from something like the red
wedding which is shocking not only that
it happens but because of how violent it
is this is I mean we don't see the
impact of the fall all we see is just
him drop and it's just like whoa it's
almost surreal but I love it
number eight Petyr Baelish I was really
tempted to put this one higher cuz I was
really ready to see him die
the
reason I didn't put this in the upper
half of the list is that the death
itself is a fairly standard one it's a
throat cut but Boyd the build-up to that
death oh do I love it I love because
this is literally the only time we've
ever seen little finger on the back foot
he's always been in control he's always
been in command he's always had a plan
he has always been on top and he's
always been smugly letting everybody
knows I got this I got this every step
of the way to just watch that fall away
and to actually watch him flounder watch
every possible escape that he can think
of just not work say when he orders take
me back to the earring it doesn't they
say no and he he just turns to Sansa who
is so perfectly cold in this scene and
just that he and the end has reduced
this pitiful begging just little shell
of a man that was perfect that that more
than death that of having everything
that he thought he was in control of
stripped away from him until all he
could do was plead perfect and the fact
that he got killed with that dagger that
he is originating from him to try and
kill brand even better number seven
Oberyn Martell this one is so brutal
that I've got to use one of the most
tone down images I can find to represent
it because the image I used to represent
in my earlier video got to got the video
flagged for being inappropriate material
so yeah this I do honestly think that
the death of Oberyn Martell might be the
single most brutal death I have seen on
any screen movie television video game
just whoa God and I mean part of it is
just maybe it's my own buttons I think
prior to this the death that made me go
uh the most was in Blade Runner um with
dr. Tyrell death in that and it was very
similar it was the same sort of head
crushy thumb and the eye thing but this
one takes that and cranks it up to past
eleven Wow
just the brutality of it and it he had
won all he had to do was not gloat but
it gave them out in that opening and
once the guy got his hands on him that
was it and man oh man Wow I actually
honestly I have not rewatched that part
of that episode I can't man
it's bit bad in like a way that I will
never forget but I also think I don't
ever want to actually watch again
number six Ramsay Bolton
here's another satisfying one not only
because of who it is who is getting the
kill I and obviously I think we were all
really really ready for Ramsay to bite
it but the dogs oh just ate his face and
again if here's Sansa calling back up on
this list just when she gets cold oh boy
she's she is scary honestly but I mean
this this was just perfect cuz this is
his own cruelty coming back to him not
just because this was a way that he had
killed other people before but because
the dogs are starving because he doesn't
care about them he doesn't care about
anything he cares about them as a means
to an end he only cares about them as a
torture and murder device so of course
he keeps them starving he doesn't care
about these dogs well you know what
buddy
you bet you really wish you'd treated
those dogs better and hadn't kept them
on the verge of starving all the time
because now you're in a doggy bag number
five Tywin Lannister this one not
dissimilar to Petyr baelish's just
something wonderfully undignified about
this death which Jay
again much like Littlefinger feels very
ironically appropriate for a character
who was always in control always in
command gets a death that nobody would
ever choose to have just sitting on the
crapper did crossbow bolts nobody would
nobody would put that on their list of
ways I would prefer to die it's just
it's embarrassing it's humiliating
and to have it be done by someone that
he thinks so little of yeah forgive the
pun but it's a perfect death committed
by just the right person in just the
right way the man who would have been
the power behind the throne dying on the
least dignified throne available number
four Joffrey Baratheon here's another
one man we waited oh he had to wait a
while for this one because even even
before Ramsay Bolton before I mean
Littlefinger I was fun Joffrey I think
we're all just gonna just die just die
well when will you die and then the
second cough you realize it's happening
and and he starts to go purple and veiny
and then just the how awful it looks and
just everybody saying I'm very clear
everyone's kind of surprised but the
only person who cares is seriously and
she goes up to him but man you're
looking around and going pretty much
everybody except the woman holding him
right now
would happily have been the one to
deliver that poison you know he's a it's
his wedding it's his one of his way too
many moments of triumph he's on top of
the world it's all about him until he
just starts to choke and discolor and
the eyes go Oh
it looked really bad which was perfect
that is what he needed and it need and
needed to be drawn out just a little bit
and it was he needed to know he was
dying and he did and it was good number
three a little bit of a different one
here Elena Tyrell possibly the least
eventful death that is gonna be on this
list Tommen was kind of uneventful too
but that had a certain shock value to it
this doesn't even have that because we
get a heads up you know before she
touches that drink what it is and she
drinks it voluntarily but she has the
only death where I think I can say went
out like a boss death is not a
particularly dignified thing in Westeros
generally when characters die it's not
nobly on the battlefield generally they
die being stabbed in the back
people don't get heroic sacrificing
death and then Elena's death here is not
particularly heroic let me be clear but
she goes out on her own terms
she downs that stuff and looks Jamie
dead in the eye
I killed Joffrey and you will get no
satisfaction out of knowing that you
won't get to take revenge what are you
gonna do it's a mic drop moment she's
just sitting there going I lost I killed
your son out peace out like a boss up to
number two and last time I did this list
this came in at my number one death
Viserys Targaryen this is what I think a
lot of people forget about because it
was a season one death and it wasn't
played in as big a moment as say Ned
Stark's death was or Khal Drogo's death
was but what a satisfying end for that
miserable little prick on so many levels
because first of all I love the irony of
it you
because he just he wants his golden
crown and also and he thinks he's safe
because they can't spill blood in the
tent but it doesn't matter
so Khal Drogo pours this molten gold
onto his head kills him without spilling
a drop of blood yet in a way that is
really horrific but is this horrible
ironic death and that is this weird
twisted version of the thing he was just
shouting that he wanted and then when he
falls and the the metal the gold has
kind of cooled a little bit of his head
clunk onto the ground oh that sound I
love that sound that that's still
probably in terms of a visceral eager
for me still the most satisfying death
but it doesn't quite make my number one
death it did last time I did this list
this time I got to put another one up
there and it is unique in this because I
said characters don't get heroic
sacrificial deaths
well there's one who did and that's my
number one and that's Hodor now we don't
actually see the moment that he dies but
we know he does and Hodor is first of
all such an endearing character and he
we've had so much time in he and he's
just been there without having to like
highlight in giving give him a very
special episode all to himself
he's just been there endearing himself
to us this whole time for years up to
this point and then when he's he's
holding the door and you see the
determination in his face holding it and
then as the flashbacks are happening and
you hear the voice calling out hold the
door and you see the younger version of
him fall to the ground and start to
convulse hold the door hold it until it
devolves into Hodor and you realize this
is literally what his life became this
moment is everything he is going to do
with his life and it has been
set in stone since he was a teenager and
it is awful and wonderful and beautiful
and tragic and sad and yet triumphant it
is this wonderful mix of all these
emotions all wrapped up in this reveal
that happens at the exact same time as
he just stands there and holds that door
for however long it is that he's going
to be able to do that and it is one of
my favorite moments in this show at all
and it is definitely my favorite death
in Game of Thrones so that's my top 10
there are a ton of great deaths I didn't
I didn't even touch on I couldn't even
get to so what are your favourite deaths
from the show are they some of the ones
I mentioned are they some of the ones I
opted to leave off whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
councils of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half of
the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]